Agriculture and
biodiversity this is a highly important
subject when man stop traveling 12,000
years ago and started having many babies
invented Agriculture and breeding and
this disrupted the ecosystem there could
be um human beings without agriculture
but there can be no humankind without
agriculture man needed to feed the
population and uh in the fields in the
19th century man stopped mixing wild
plants and cultivated plants in the
fields then everything
changed uh irrigation was invented
plants were selected genetic work
started in sensive aromy with high
levels of pesticides insecticides many
babies were born and the human
population is multiplied by three
between 1950 and today and the
agriculture had to keep pace and what we
thought was the ideal situation started
being challenged in the 70s and
80s the dark clouds started accumulating
over humankind best icid insecticides
soil pollution destruction of pollinator
insects pollinator insects are
absolutely vital because except for a
few plants such as cereals uh many
plants are pollinated fruit and flowers
and if we lost them the loss would be
180 billion a year to pay the women who
would have to uh replace bees and
pollinate plants manually so this is the
challenge we can't increase uh arable
surface we have to stop wasting water
and uh we have to uh try to suppress
pesticides uh decrease the use of
fertiliz fertilizers used biodiversity
to maintain uh Manpower in agriculture
not too much mechanization we have to
allow Farmers to work and be proud of
their job because uh the fact that we
lose agriculture in the mountains is
also a sign of loss of biodiversity and
when we talk about biodiversity I'll
give you a case there was uh rice
dwarfing a viral epidemic in 2007 and
obviously this had an impact on millions
of people in the local population it was
necessary to test 6,300 varieties of
rice to find one lost in a Himalayan
Valley that resisted the virus now
nowadays this species is cultivated over
100,000 square kilometers in Asia this
is biodiversity um at it best bringing a
response a reply to a problem and a lost
Himalayan Valley rice species allowed to
solve the problem so we need to PR bi
preserve biodiversity in plants and
animals we need to control the animal
population there are far too many cows
on Earth 1.5 billion cows far too many
we need to respect nature we need to
create agroecology intensively and also
organic growing but we can't grow plants
organically everywhere we simply want to
make sure that we need to feed seven and
very soon 9 billion human beings on
Earth providing uh protein and also uh
Distributing uh the resources better
across the world this is a huge
challenge Agriculture and biodiversity